löw ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft weil eben älter er wurde
zusammen mit kates küchen und mücken
bergmann diesmal nicht weil der
wahrscheinlich also der cadooz und
herbert mann waren ja offenbar
videopreis alles nähere dazu macht das
in einem meinung wie deo hast du gerade
schon gesagt was beide sind wie sie
durch die gegend gefilmt da wird dann
wieder irgendwie so ein very good luck
draus gemacht und hat ein eigenes video
oder sowas
bergmann ist wahrscheinlich noch da ist
ein bisschen länger auf der
aftershowparty geblieben als ich erkläre
das jetzt mal so und vielleicht liegt ja
einfach nur so in den seilen ich bin
auch man hört vielleicht ich bin ein
bisschen krank also ich habe mich auch
aus dem bett gequält für die aufnahme
hier und funktioniere durch die
wunderbare heilungs kraft eines aspirin
complex drogencocktails also bei mir
fängt auch langsam die tablettensucht an
obwohl das sehr kalte betten sind
sondern granulat aber kurz kurz gesagt
bergmann ist gerade eben unpässlich
leider das wird sich wie wir sind da
dran dass wir das irgendwann mal
irgendwie hinbekommen das wirklich hier
immer alle drei anwesend sind das haben
wir schon mal erklärt dass das schwierig
ist aber jetzt bekommt er halt wieder so
eine ersatz folge mit mir und luca
zusammen der es nennt sich zuerst aber
das sollte hoffentlich glücklich stimmen
oder sona gucken dass man morgen
irgendwie soll es ja auch beim bergbahn
online kommen und nicht bei irgendwem
von uns deswegen wird da wird er schon
hoffentlich irgendwie wieder die die
gebote dreier konstellation am start
sein
ja genau also wie kates eltern gesagt
hat bergmann ist zurzeit also wir wissen
nicht genau was es bei skype online aber
es kann natürlich auch sein man weiß ja
dass er vor dem ganzen 100 videopreis
erlanger an diesem film geschnitten hat
und da recht wenig schlaf hat also und
40 stunden am tag habe ich drei stunden
geschlafen was hat man hat mich auch
wirklich angesetzt also nicht böse
gemeint aber
da hat er wirklich sagen dass das
herzblut reingesteckt oder ist sie mir
jetzt mal ein bisschen das bisschen ruhe
sei ihm auch gegönnt
deswegen wir wollen jetzt nicht
irgendwie ja groß dienstag mit
deswegen haben und ich gesagt kommt
unternehmen jetzt zu zweit allein auf ok
das ja auch schon angeschlagen ist aber
ich wollte zwar nicht so alleine hier
aufnehmen weil das ganze projekt ja in
letzter zeit ein bisschen chaotisch ist
das ist halt einfach weil so ein paar
dinge letzter zeit passieren also dass
herr berg und diesen film schneidet oder
dass der video preis oder oder oder
und deswegen haben wir uns gedacht wir
machen jetzt schön eine chillige folge
wo wir einfach ein bisschen bauen ich
war mir gerade noch ein bisschen was zu
fressen und danach wollte ich mich auch
und ich wollte mich mal ein bisschen
umgucken aus welchen materialien ich
eigentlich mein haus bauen könnte was
hast du da eigentlich für holz ich habe
ganz ganz viele verschiedene holzsorten
ich bin auch noch so herum probieren was
jetzt irgendwie am ende wirklich fesselt
mich aber war schon irgendwie was ist um
andrew wood place und da gibt es ja auch
noch jacaranda gut und es gibt ja noch
magic wood also wie gesagt ist ja leider
nutzt deswegen gibt es wahrscheinlich so
viele holz orten wie ich mal hinaus und
kann man schon viel mit rum bauen also
ich finde eine holzhütte ich auch ganz
passend ich weiß es das geschehe das rad
sei eine holzhütte wir jedem projekt
blablabla aber hier passt das ja so
kleines holzhäuschen im wald finde ich
dann doch ganz ganz praktisch ich mache
mir jetzt erst mal ganz kurz hier so
eine crazy kiste und crazy crazy kiss
ich musste ja auf jeden fall
irgendwelche kohleblöcke raus und ich
wollte irgendetwas zu boden weiß nicht
ich wollte ja so aufs meer ziehen aber
dann weiß nicht ob das dann noch
holzhütte werden soll oder irgendwas auf
stelzen
ich bin eigentlich noch relativ
unentschlossen wie ich das ganze mache
ich glaube ich mache hier sogar einen
kleinen bis jetzt habe ich einfach meine
kiste eingesetzt sondern so einen
kleinen weg oder so ich weiß echt nicht
so genau
ich glaube ich laufe einfach mal ein
bisschen rum und schaue mir an wie
welches volk so aussieht an ich bin in
der letzten folge auch schon heftig um
gelaufen man noch etwas machen luca hier
komme ich fange jetzt mal zu bauen ein
baum x bow mal einfach irgendwas egal
die sache aussieht
diese hübsche als mainz passt irgendwie
auch man ja ich habe ich habe ich habe
aber dafür brauche ich so richtig coole
stimme
und sind die coolsten dass das bestimmt
nicht schon also das kann aber sagen
dass sich hier auch so für für die
seiten so ein bisschen aber ich bin noch
nicht so wird schon nach irgendwas
irgendwie irgendwo aussehen und da
steckt ganz viel plan dahinter
vielleicht auch keiner aber wo man halt
echt krass dass du dass deine stimme so
richtig angeschlagen ist ja die stimme
die stimme ist gar nicht so angeschlagen
als es ist deutlich besser im vergleich
zu gestern aber das ist so also meine
nase ist eigentlich ziemlich zu oder in
seinem komischen misch zustand und das
wahrscheinlich ist irgendwie man jetzt
meinen reifen schauen würde dann würde
das aussehen wie in so einer ekelhaften
höhle ausmaß so viel schreiben ist da
drin ich weiß es symbolisch und sowas
aber dann wird man wird meine stimme
zudem bot stocks play das ich machen
werde passt dann wieder eine weil dann
kannst du weniger zeit so tun als hätte
so eine epische stimme und in der
nächsten folge klingt dann wieder wie
schon die reifen bekommen auf myvideo
preis ich habe ja der fest irgendwie mit
dem ehrenpreis gerechnet hier für den
für den kleinsten youtuber weltweit aber
irgendwie nicht funktioniert dann haben
die außenseiter bekomme ich war ja auch
gar nicht nominiert also ich war ja im
jahr zuvor nominiert und dieses jahr ich
will dass da mal nicht gegeben
vielleicht nächstes jahr wieder weil das
natürlich auch immer so einen gewissen
zeitlichen aufwand bedeutet seine
community gut zum boden zu mobilisieren
da wir jetzt nicht gerade im it channel
mit mehreren millionen abos ist aber ich
war wirklich einfach nur als als als
zuschauer dieses jahr mal da und das hat
auch gut spaß gemacht da einfach mal
jetzt da zu sein ohne irgendwie die
angst zu haben dass das wird ja auf
einer leinwand gezeigt also die
nominierten logischerweise hier ist bei
einer gala als üblich ist und ich weiß
auch dass ich damals dann im jahr zuvor
ist so ein bisschen bammel hatte das bei
mir einfach niemand applaudiert wird das
video kommt schließt das kommt das kommt
ja und dann war es ja aber auch wirklich
manchmal so dass das recht der platz
zurückhaltend war ja genau das fand ich
traurig du du fühlst fühlt sich dann
halt schon so ein bisschen ja auch wenn
die leute jetzt irgendwie gar nicht und
bin ich dann uncool und sowas aber das
war damals war ja der war ja auch mit
motiven
motiviert war bestimmt aber hier war ja
auch letztes jahr und hat sogar die frau
damals für mich mit applaudiert als er
gesehen hat dass den upload glaube ich
also das war aber irgendwie war
irgendwie ganz coole nummer und war war
sehr schön im letzten jahr und wie ich
es dieses jahr fand erfährt man nur um
einen kanal jetzt nicht zu viel vorweg
zu nehmen ich glaube ich glaube das wird
cool also wenn ich wenn ich das umsetzen
kann wie ich mir das vorstelle aber
hoffe ich kann jetzt mal übrigens auch
sagen wenn ich hier die chance gehabt
nutze das eher sogar gar kein thema
haben ich werde mich bald komplett
umstellen also ich ja gott wird ja bald
umziehen das ist aber nicht das einzige
sondern ich habe mir schon alles
mögliche bestellt aber ich wollte also
ich habe mir ein neues mikrofon
bestellten besser und ich glaube das
habe ich noch gar nicht gesehen
irgendwie das ist auch relativ neu ist
aber voll geil aus und glaubt dass wir
wollen die videos cool aussehen und
hammer kommen von der qualität und dann
habe ich ein neues interface bestellt
zwei neue da das gemeine volk ist kann
ich das einmal jeden kollegen auch ich
würde erstmal weil ich habe mit lukas
natürlich in den letzten tagen weil ich
andauernd weg war weniger quatschen
können als wir das sonst inzwischen tun
und deswegen haube heraus tun
und unser ziel von von seinen plänen
eben noch mal ganz kurz nach 10 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 9
ok 10 ist abstand also wirklich ich habe
mir ein neues mikrofon bestellt ich habe
mir zwei neue led video beleuchtungen
bestellt also nicht so softbox ist
sondern etwas anderes mal wollte ich mal
testen dann zwar neue stative dann
neue das habe ich schon interface habe
ich ja schon gesagt ich habe jetzt auch
endlich geht aus einer webcam bestellt
sind ja noch ein bisschen am hätten über
unsere jetzige worden weil ich auch
einfach grundsätzlich scheiße ist dies
einfach nur das muss man einfach sagen
es geht also seit ich mit openbroadcast
das ganze mehr ist deutlich besser als
mit dem internen programm aber so macht
sich die broadcaster mittlerweile so
alles aufnehmen
genau ich wollte das eigentlich nämlich
alles direkt auf das wird ja gar nicht
gehen weil ich ja auch meine videos noch
schneiden und in trotha vorbei und so
was das würde einfach nicht
funktionieren
ja aber ich sage ich das mache geht es
eindeutig besser und ist nicht mehr ganz
so ganz so sperrig wieder vor weil auch
irgendwie das wird kein programm muss
man sich so vorstellen
speichert die die einstellung abspeckt
sich ab und zu hier ein rum du kannst
mit dem web programm ist webcam programm
kenner sein das ist so klar genau du
kannst es komplett knicken irgendwie
auch im vollbildmodus aufzunehmen das
weil das web kamera und 23 sekunden
aufnimmt und dann einfach nicht mehr
macht und das ist natürlich extrem
schwierig und ja also das was hast du
denn geholt vereine ganz so das sagen
was über hast weißt du dass du kommst du
ich hab mir jetzt irgendwann den aber
ich wollte das alles so nach also sage
ich vielleicht nach aufnahme was ich mir
alles holen werde damit bis zum 3
manni regelt wo sollte ich erst mal ganz
kurz fragt wo soll ich erde holen ohne
dass sich unsere landschaft großartig
kaputt mache weil ich weiß nicht wie
viel du hier von den berg noch haben
willst ich hätte gerne bergmann der
auflage kommen wieder kommen wieder die
worte beziehung die glauben das ist mir
eigentlich völlig wurscht solange es
jetzt sich nachher aussieht als hätte
sie gerade eben den wald gerodet kannst
du da einfach einfach macht macht wieder
das komm ich lese es nicht ich sterbe
gerade irgendwie an hunger oder ich bin
vergiftet oder keine ahnung aber ich bin
damit einfach nie mit einfach mit luca
hierbei auch ein super video gesehen
beim sturm auf dem kanal
jawohl dann einfach den kinos naja das
war das was über lustig haben wir uns
irgendwie das war so die die kennenlern
stunde und dann sind wir beim also ich
war ja mit dem mit dem dach mit indie
labels zusammen in einem zimmer
und dann sind wir zu strom normal
besuchen gekommen gegangen gegangen
gekommen und da ich mir als den netten
seinem mac rom und ich dachte mir so
irgendwie möchte ich das mal es gibt ja
so diese direkt funktion von youtube
aufzunehmen und einfach die webcam
anzuschmeißen reinzureden und juden jahr
komplettiert und lädt das direkt hoch
funktioniert nicht gut weil das video
hat geholt die sau aber zumindest der
ton war da und dachte ich mir dass amys
kanal mal kurz fluten kam auch gut bei
den beiden bei den sturm waffen an hier
hätte ich gar nicht gedacht aber das hat
den heim ein anderes gesicht dass dieser
brauch werden eure duschen seien auch
selbst ohne witz dass da habe ich auch
noch ich hoffe ich nicht mehr so viel
vorweg wenn du deine meinung wieder zum
video
das ist ja ist ja nur so ein bisschen an
diesen und das kann man auch in dem blog
sehen und so und drum und dran und das
ist jetzt nicht so mega die überraschung
aber das kurz zu erklären
für die für die abonnenten von diakonie
wir haben es halt im doppelzimmer
gewählt weil ich dass ich finde es halt
ganz lustig so ein bisschen dieses
klassenfahrt widing zu haben deswegen
hatte ich auch kein problem damit eben
mit dario zusammen im zimmer zu gehen
würde ich dann problem hatte war dass
das bad eben einfach nicht abgetrennt
war sogar mitten im raum stand und du
halt wirklich 1a sehen konnte es wenn
jemand duscht konntest du halt sehen wir
durch das war halt kein irgendwie
verschwommen ist glas sondern halten
komplett durchsichtig ist und das war
dann halt irgendwie ja da muss man sich
ein bisschen ein bisschen arrangieren
hat sich dann immer einer die ecke
gestellt und geheult weil es ja
schrecklich mir beim duschen zuschauern
ich meine dass hier liegt ja man was
eigentlich mittlerweile im bett ach ich
hab ja soviel folge geholt hat wir ins
bett machen können echt ja ja dann kommt
zu mir da auf dem steg ich komme zu dir
hoffentlich mal kurze beine
ich hab kein thema gestellt das heißt
zeigen ja ich gucke die ganze jahr über
sind zwölf minuten war eben dann bringt
das ganze langsam zum ende bringen
zum ende da wie du das auch noch
pünktlich opladen klasse 3b schön das
super ich gehe da mal baden und meiner
rolle habe ich bin ja ausgeschriebene
beckmesser übrigens beim bettnässer
verein beitreten will den werde ich auch
bald gründen möchten ist der vereinigung
deutschlands
gibt es gibt bestimmt wo es ist
irgendwie so ein verein für todkranke
kinder oder so denn ich jetzt wieder
warschau ps kommen da kommt mein bett
mit dem embed hinsetzen kommt mitten im
wald logischerweise in meine in meiner
bude du weißt dass du dann aber von
monstern geweckt werden kann es ja das
ist dass die bewussten kommen jetzt
schlafen hallo ich werde hoffentlich
nicht von monstern angegriffen
ich werde euch angegriffen das ist das
dritte gesetz schreiben das jahr jetzt
könnt ihr auch schlafen leitende woods
also fortschritt ohne ende ich habe mein
haus umgebaut und morgen wird es dann
hoffentlich hoffentlich die folge war
bergmann geben falls ich irgendetwas
ändert werdet ihr das bestimmt
mitbekommen wenn dann spätestens die
folge wieder auf meinem teller kommen
aber die kriegen das schon irgendwie
geklärt wir hoffen natürlich auch dass
es euch nicht zu sehr stört der muss
jetzt wieder gedacht besser jugend eine
folge als keine folge hier drängt sich
natürlich meist wieder hat man das
projekt ist so blöd da ist er mir na da
ja mal versuchen sie in zukunft zu
regeln nur ist halt wirklich zwei drei
leuten aufnahmetermin zu finden bei drei
leuten die sehr sehr viel zu tun haben
ist das ganze sehr schwer also
eigentlich mal und soll das ich würde es
bestimmt wird sich bestimmt alles alles
klären wir versuchen zumindest irgendwie
professionell zu sein wir schaffen es
nicht immer aber der versuch ist
zumindest da bei mir soll es übrigens
jetzt in der nächsten folge die dann
hoffentlich beim bergmann auf dem kanal
kommt da wissen wir ja noch nicht wie es
möglich sein wird ich würde jetzt mal
einfach sagen ja wir kriegen das schon
irgendwie hin werde ich versuchen mein
haus gezogen bis weiter zu bauen dass
sie da gerade noch so ein bisschen crazy
komisch aus hier aber es soll aufs
wasser gehen und das wird glaube ich
sehr cool und dann will ich sagen ich
gehe vom server herunter wenn es euch
gefallen hat zeigt uns mit einem mag ich
und dann sehen wir uns in der nächsten
folge wieder wann wir wieder themen
benutzen sagen wir dann mal
und tschüss